what would your musical influence is
growing up as a kid clearly you more
listening to different kinds of music
but I have no idea what they were I
never really got past the seventies you
know sort of stones Beatles The Doors
Bowie made punk rock Siouxsie and the
Banshees
you know where I go back to it's funny
so much of that makes sense to me but
when you say the doors I don't hear that
influence I hear right with the doors
Georgia red alright nothing I feel like
I'm in a bar fight now Jim Jim Morrison
had the best yell and it was beautiful
to get the best yell to this day no one
had a better yell are you you both love
the doors she had the best yell but who
do you think had the best yell Jim
Morrison yeah well why don't you if you
both love the doors so much why don't
you both sing a doors
you okay with that yeah all right hold
on Jimmy Jimmy do you know any Doris
songs not really but I know who does the
guitarist of the doors where I'll be
Krieger right here
[Applause]
[Music]
won't you tell me your name hello I love
you let me jump in your game hello I
love you won't you tell me your name
hello I love you let me jump in your
game she's war
ooh
I love you tell me
hello I love you let me jump in your
cake hello I love you too tell me your
name hello I love you let me jump in
your cake
[Applause]
[Music]
wicked little huh when she brews
brain Springs Arkansas
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Culture Club Pizza
exactly the North American tour this
Friday July 17th at the Hard Rock Casino
in Vancouver Canada for tickets go to
board Gorge UK dot-com Boy George
[Applause]